we have seen all five of the nominated  songs presented tonight and now it's  time to recap the choices and announce  the Oscar winner they are in  alphabetical order from Young Guns to  blaze of glory music and lyric by Jon  Bon Jovi from postcards from the edge  I'm checking out music and lyric by shel  silverstein from The Godfather Part 3  promise me you will remember music by  carmine Coppola lyric by John Bettis  from home alone summer in my memory  music by John Williams lyric by Leslie  burkas Dick Tracy sooner or later I  always get my man music and lyric by  Stephen Sondheim and the Oscar goes to  Stephen Sondheim for sooner or later I  always put my man  the Academy congratulates stephen  sondheim and accepts understand  you  you